a couple of more about you
so okay everybody
to to have you all uh for uh synthesis
of models and system workshop
so we have the great pleasure to have a
speaker today uh jiva allure who's the
sisman family professor
of computer information science at the
university of pennsylvania
so rajiv research is focused on formal
methods for system design
and spans cyber physical systems
programming languages and
theoretical computer science rajiv is a
fellow
of aaas a fellow of acm a fellow of ieee
and
an alfred p sloan faculty fellow and a
science investigator
he was awarded an inaugural cav award in
2008
the acm ieee logic and computer science
test of time award in 2010 the inaugural
alonzo church award
by acm sieglock the atcs could go the
society in 2016
the distinguished alumnus award from iit
kanpur in 2017 for his work on time
automata
so rajiv served as the chair of acm
siegbed
uh the general chair of leaks and he
uh was the lead pi of the nsf
expeditions in company
is probably still i don't know whether
the project is
ended the nsf expeditions in the
computing center escape expeditions in
computer
augmented program engineering and
actually his talk uh
is using part of
the results of this project that he
where he was a lead
guy and rajiv is also an author of a
textbook on the principle of cyber
physical systems
that appeared in mit press 2015
so as you can see we have a really
heavy heavy weight talking today so
a brace for an amazing talk and i must
say that i i
had the great pleasure and opportunity
to work with rajiv
by the end of the previous century and
it was a great pleasure working so rajiv
the floor is yours and thank you very
much for
giving the talk today yeah thank you
radu for
that nice introduction it's really a
pleasure
to be here so thank you all the
organizers to give me this opportunity
to talk about work we have been doing on
program synthesis
and as radu said so this work started in
as part of nsf expeditions project
where the goal was to integrate many of
the ideas that
were around in program synthesis into
some common infrastructure and some
common computational core and we call
this problem syntax guided
synthesis and that's so so i'm going to
give you a tutorial focused
on that today and the
it's supposed to be for two hours so but
but i hope it involves a lot of
discussion so feel free to
interrupt me at any point in time and
ask questions
or you can also post your question in
the chat window
and uh what what i'm planning to do is
to maybe talk for an hour take like a
few minutes break and then
we will continue and at the end of the
talk
uh we will leave aside some time to
focus
on a future directions and then
maybe we can have more discussion
so i want to start this tutorial by
first
giving you a general overview of what
synthesis is about and what syntax
guided synthesis is about
and focusing on the questions
of why and what right
so the background for uh synthesis is
actually the success that formal
verification has had in practice
uh so when i started working on formal
verification and this was actually in
late
1980s so at that point a verification
which it refers to
checking that the program or a system
for uh
satisfies a correctness property and
trying to formalize that claim as a
rigorous mathematical claim and then
building tools to verify that the model
or the
program actually satisfies this property
so this idea of formal verification even
though it started
at the beginning of computer science in
1960s
with uh you know a groundbreaking work
of uh
people like tony hoare and dykstra
so when i started working on this in the
late 80s it was
still had not transitioned to
uh industry so it was always viewed as a
desirable goal
but the technology wasn't ready but over
the last
20 30 years i think there has been
enormous progress
in verification and a number of
companies have now
adopted uh verification as part of their
technology
so it's not still like a
a technology that's commonly used by all
software developers
but in niche pockets uh within industry
it's
definitely used and in particular
uh right now a company such as
amazon in its aws group uh they have
a very vibrant and thriving group of
researchers focused on verification
and they are building tools so that the
they can give
better assurance guarantees about the
cloud infrastructure
so that's great you know it's kind of a
success of
uh transfer of technology from academia
to industry
and but that uh uh
uh raises this question that as
academics what should we be
now focused on it and can we try to go
beyond verification and testing
and the answer here is one potential
answer is to start looking at program
synthesis
so program synthesis means different
things to different people
the definition that i like the most is
articulated in this
wonderful article by david harrell in an
ieee computer article
in 2008 and the title of the article
says
can programming be liberated period and
that really
is the vision that i think
is it's a good vision to have that even
though
programming has evolved so much uh
you know from say 1960s to now
it's still focused on the programmer
thinking about all the corner cases
filling in
all the tedious details and the level of
abstraction has raised
it has been raised through a lot of
advances in programming abstractions and
compiler technology
and verification technology but still
uh the programming uh the way the
programmer conveys
the intent to the computer it's still
you know in in a very uh using very
rigid framework
of some well-defined programming
languages right and
this in this article it thinks about
different ways
potentially programmer could communicate
the intent
and this uh it's still a dream but there
are lots of technologies which are
now uh uh can help us to
move towards it so there is a lot more
computing power available so questions
that were
viewed computationally infeasible a
decade or two ago are now
possible the verification tools have
matured
the hci technology is evolving
rapidly the the nlp technology is also
evolving
and that's uh so that's a reason for
hope
the uh so but that's a more long-term
goal that you know programmers will
actually convey their intent
in very different ways but
the focus uh for this talk and the
framework of syntax guided synthesis was
motivated by these four
concrete applications uh so one is
programming by examples
uh the second one is about super
optimizing compilers the third one
is kind of local edits to programs
what's what we call program repair
and the fourth is or enabling uh
as an enabling technology for
verification itself so
uh synthesizing proof objects and i will
give you
uh uh intuitive examples of these
four uh applications in the in the next
few
minutes uh so first let's look at
programming by examples
and here is my uh favorite example
because it's very easy to explain and
it's from this very old book
called hacker's delight and
this hacker's delight book contains lots
of
very clever low level c programs
and here is one example so suppose the
transformation that you want to do
is a transformation on bit vectors
and what we want to do is to reset
the rightmost substring of contiguous
ones
to zeros so writing this
as a program can be a bit challenging i
mean of course you can write
a loop which uh you know uh uh where you
start
scanning the bits one by one starting at
the right most
end and then look for the contiguous
sequence of ones
but you can actually specify this more
intuitively
and more easily just using a few input
output examples
so here you know on this slide i have
shown three now so for example you know
the third example says
that if the input vector is one zero one
one zero
it should be transformed to one zero
then the
the the two ones uh change to zeros and
right so so uh
even for an ex you know even for experts
writing this program could be more
challenging
but uh giving examples i think it's uh
we can all agree that it's easy it's an
easy thing to do
for expressing intent for all kinds of
uh
programmers expert programmers beginning
programmers students
people don't even who don't know that
much about programming right
and what we want to synthesize is then
is a program
constructed from standard bit vector
operations
in c now the c uh language actually
offers
a large variety of bit vector operations
and
you know there are shifts and bitwise
ants and so on
and it turns out the simplest program
which can implement this
uh it's kind of cryptic but uh
where here x is viewed as a vector and
is bitwise
and and plus is bitwise r and so on
so the uh so the exact details of this
program
uh are not relevant for the talk but
this is something that the current
synthesis technology can
do which is takes a few examples and
take the space
of programs through which it's searching
and come up with this solution right
of course uh you know if you haven't
seen this the you would
immediately start asking questions like
can we specify the program
unambiguously using a few examples and
how can we provide support
to the user so that they converge on the
right program
and also how do we actually search
because even though you know this
program
seems small the there are lots of
operators and the search space is going
to grow exponentially so how do we
manage that complexity right
but these are exactly the kinds of
questions that the
synthesis research attempts to address
and this programming by examples which
actually can be in fact useful in an
industrial context
and this is a nice success of this and
this is
a project at micros started as a mic a
research
uh project at microsoft research by
sumit gulvani and it's called flash fill
and this is in the context of
transformations
in excel spreadsheet which is used by
millions and millions of people and if
you have used excel you would
know that you know excel provides lots
of built-in transformations to generate
columns
from the existing columns by you know if
you just wanted to add two numbers you
know you can just press on add and then
it will create a column which adds those
to the
columns but if i have a slightly more
complicated task
and what you see here in my example is
that the left column has
some telephone numbers these are the us
telephone numbers
and the right hand column shows these
numbers
in some cleaned up format right and
it's if you think about the the program
that's actually doing this
transformation
it's going to be some string
transformation but even with these
examples you can realize that oh this
string transformation could be kind of
complicated right and
if it's not provided as a built-in
functionality
for an end user to figure out this
string transformation is going to be
complicated
so even though excel provides some
built-in macro language to write string
transformations
very few people will be able to write
the desired
program in this case but to give
examples is very easy in this case you
could just highlight a few rows and then
show what
what output you want and then what the
synthesis tool is going to do
is to search through the space of
string transformation programs that can
be written
in excel's macro language and find the
one
that best meets the user intent
as demonstrated by a few examples
and so this actually idea appeared in
the purple paper in 2011
and then uh you know microsoft really
liked it and it was then integrated in
excel and it's now shipped
with excel and this is a quote from
wired which says
that oh you know why uh why didn't uh pl
folks figure out this type of feature
uh already this makes perfect sense
and uh this programming by examples is
is the right thing to do
in this context
uh and here is my uh another example
actually more recent
and this is based on a project at
university of washington
where now what we want to do is
synthesize sql queries
and so on the right hand side you see a
sql query
and specifying it again requires
some training so of course we teach all
undergraduate
students when they take database course
you know how to write queries in sql
but it's highly specialized and on the
left what you see is just one example
where
t1 and t2 are input tables and out is
the
output table for this specific input
tables
and the uh what the synthesis tool then
does
is uses these examples to generate this
sql queries and this is implemented in
this tool called skype
so the second example i wanted to give
about synthesis
was to do with program optimization
uh and so this so the
programming by examples was aimed at
end users people with no not much
programming background
can they express uh the logic and in
that context it had to be very simple
logic
using input output examples at the other
end
maybe programmers are experts but
they want to extract very high
performance from
their code and so in the innermost loop
they want to do very efficient
computations
or maybe they want to port it to a new
platform and then
the the intricate details of that new
platform are slightly different
and they want to see if
how best to optimize the existing code
on this new platform right
and so this uh in the uh
in compiler uh literature this would be
called super optimization so
so i want to really optimize the code if
say
if i have 10 instructions from that i
want to go to eight instructions
so that type of transformations cannot
be done by traditional
compiler optimizations that you see
let's say in a gnu compiler
because all those optimizations
typically are
structured preserving their local their
semantics preserving code
transformations for example
removing an update to a variable from
inside the loop to outside the loop if
certain conditions are satisfied
but in in the setting of the super
optimization the transformed code may
look very different
and this actually is an active area of
research and i'm going to just show you
a simple example
to just to give you a flavor of uh
you know what one could do though the
example is pretty simple here
uh so here i want to take average of
two numbers x and y so these are
integers and let's say they are 32-bit
integers
and if we just say set the average to be
x
plus y over 2 that actually is not quite
correct
because uh that could cause an overflow
and so this is so uh people who are
building like
uh uh core libraries they would
avoid this type of a mistake where uh
taking average by adding two numbers uh
is kind of a no-no because that could
cause a number
right so how do you do this well uh if
if if you want to do it correctly this
is one way to do it
so you uh you know you put
x to a 64-bit
vector x1 so you know so x is a 32-bit
number and x1 is a 64-bit number
so then if you change x and y-to 64-bit
numbers then you can add them
and you can be sure that there is no
overflow and then divide by 2
and then you know that the result has to
be 32-bit number so you can then drop
off
the higher order 32 bits right here
so this actually turns out to be
inefficient so it's correct
but we can think of this as the
specification
and then ask ourselves can i do without
using 64-bit numbers
and this is something that you even you
know if you think about
it you would be hard-pressed to do it
and
uh it turns out this is the answer here
again the cryptic looking program
which uses exxon and ants and shift
rights and
and the uh it's semantically equivalent
to the
program that uh you know that's shown
above and does not use any 64-bit
numbers
and can be proved semantically
equivalent and
is small enough that our current
synthesis tools can synthesize
the third example i had mentioned was
program repair
and this can be best illustrated in the
context of giving feedback
to programming homeworks by students
right and this is an example
derived from a paper by rishab singh
on a tool called autograder and this was
published in pldi 2013
so what you see here is a python program
that you know a student could have been
asked to write in an introductory
programming course and here the goal was
to
compute the derivative of a polynomial
so the input polynomial
is represented as a list of numbers
and the those numbers encode the
coefficients of the polynomial
and the program and the programming
assignment was to output
uh the list of numbers that correspond
to the coefficients
of the output polynomial and the output
polynomial is supposed to be the
derivative of the input polynomial right
again the exact you know we don't have
to go through this code but this is
a solution that the student submitted
and
typical uh uh tool
for testing student solutions would just
run this code on a few inputs
and match them against outputs and if
it's uh
not quite correct they would say oh you
know your output is not right on this
specific input
and then the student would have to go
figure out you know what went wrong
and particularly when they are just
learning to program
that could uh drive them to frustration
right
so what we want to do is to give very
accurate feedback
and how can we give very accurate
feedback well if i can do
a number of edits to this code and see
which of the edited version
actually is correct then i can
take the diff between the corrected
version and the original version
and then give the student a very precise
feedback right
and that's what this tool does so what
it needs is the
student solution that's you know there's
something like this that's submitted
a reference solution and some edit model
or you know what are the typical errors
that the student is likely to make well
for example
you know some someone may think the in
the in this
array indices start from one instead of
zero well
then you know you could change ones to
zeros and so on right yeah
uh and then the synthesis task is to
find a minimum number of edits
to the program so that uh the student
solution becomes equivalent to
the reference solution so how do you
check this program equivalence well it
could be
through some tests or it could be using
verification technology so that's kind
of
orthogonal to the way you look for the
best but the synthesis
uh tools task is to just try out these
different edits
it's of course a large space so there is
still this issue of how do you search
in a in an efficient way and then uh
so this specific tool then would come up
with uh
the following feedback saying you know
your program requires exactly these
three changes
right and the this is so the only
technology which can actually
identify such correlated errors which
are very low level
is based on program synthesis
and my final example and i'm you know i
i'm going to
uh show this quickly is to actually
generate
uh invariance automatically and
so this is a an example
program with doubly nested loop for
selection sorts
and what we want to prove is at the end
that this array is sorted it contains
numbers in increasing order uh so the
key challenge in
doing such a proof is coming up with
this invariance
and if the user provides this in
variance loop in variance
then the verification technology is at a
stage where they could actually
uh check that it's a correct right but
then the challenge is how do you come up
with this in variance
and this the synthesis based solution is
that you ask
the user to give some kind of a template
for these
in variants so for example the the first
invariant here says that
well it involves these auxiliary
variables k1 and k2
in addition to the program variables and
then
it's a conjunction of two atomic
conditions over all these variables
and you can then give this to the
synthesis tools and it can fill in those
blanks
and say uh say that oh this is the
invariant that you want right
so so instead of specifying the exact
invariance here the
the very the person who is doing the
verification
has supplied some templates for these
invariants
and then the synthesis tool has filled
in that template
so things that you see in red those are
the tricky ones to figure out
and then the it's guaranteed that this
is actually an invalid
right so i have shown you basically
these four examples you know it's a
programming by examples
program super optimization program
repair and template guided
invariant generation and uh
so when we started this work we realized
that you know there are
uh the computational problem at the core
of all these synthesis
projects is finding a program that
meets a syntactic constraint right and
so in the case of template guided
invariant generation the template was
the syntactic constraint for the
invariance that we were looking for
and a semantic constraint so for example
in the invariant generation problem the
semantic constraint would be
that the the synthesized invariant is
indeed
inductive so it's preserved by the loop
for example
and uh so we want so this is the core
computational problem
and that motivated us to define this
problem of syntax guided program
synthesis
so to contrast it with the classical
program synthesis
which was actually formalized by church
in 1957
where the uh so to uh in
in classical synthesis you have a
logical specification
or you know what the program should be
doing and the synthesizer is supposed to
generate the implementation so the
specification
is uh in the classical setting it's a
logical relation between the inputs x
and outputs y
so it's it's a formula in whatever logic
that you pick
so phi of x y and the synthesizer
is trying to do a constructive proof
of the following higher order formula
there exists
a function f such that for all inputs x
the the desired logical relationship
between x and the output produced by
f on x hopes it and
the constructive proof here also
will give you the function f of x right
and there has been decades of research
in actually realizing this goal
and so for example kestrel uh has
a variety of tools where they in fact
rooted in constructive mathematics uh
where you actually try to construct this
function f
but this turns out to be a very hard
problem and for the kinds of
problems that we looked at programming
by examples or some local repairs to the
programs
this is i think a too heavy
a solution and so the syntax guided
approach
then is to have an additional input to
the synthesizer which is the syntactic
specification
and it's going to be a set of
expressions which
we will see how it's formalized in a few
minutes but
can be specified by context-free grammar
and then
the key difference is that the
synthesizer is now doing a search
uh of course in one may argue that in
any uh uh proof uh
based techniques you are also doing a
search but here it's actually the search
is more explicit
you are explicitly searching and this
could be using
uh optimized search or could be using
machine learning techniques you are
searching for an expression in the set e
of expressions
such that uh the the expression
satisfies the logical formula
and now checking that this uh
synthesized expression size
satisfies the logical formula can be
done using
existing verification tools right so we
call this
syntax guided synthesis uh scigirls for
short
and this website here scigirs.org
has a lot of information about this
project so i'm going to now tell you
about foreign
but it would be a good time to get uh
yeah oh you know to
have some questions yeah yeah so so this
is radu so
if you go back to the previous slide
i was wondering this input output
you have that example where you had the
strings and you were
zeroing the the ones the sequences of
ones
so would this be a set of expressions
i mean so would be considered i mean
these examples
yeah no that's a good question no so
that so that will be encoded in the
logical formula
so the logic the this so so the semantic
specification in that case
will say that if x is equal to this
let's say 0 1 0
then uh x equal to 0 1 0
implies y equal to say 0 0 0
so you know so the example okay and the
set of expression would be the program
would be the end and the order and this
operation that you
learned the set of expressions would be
all
uh uh c programs that you can construct
using the bitwise
uh you know the operations and bit
vectors
and how do you do the searches uh i i
assume that these are not you cannot do
kind of gradient or something like this
so you just do a
complete search or how how do you search
for the
yes no so yeah we will get to that yeah
all right so yeah so i'm going to tell
you about
the current techniques that i have been
used in search
thank you so i see some other guys
looking like
russ do you have some question maria
um yes thank you i only have a comment
about
the history the very early history
you had the page about also church
in initiating the first definition of
synthesis
but i remember reading once that also
at the very beginning of artificial
intelligence
people thought that uh generating
programs would be a sign
of artificial intelligence of the
computer
and back then they called it automatic
programming harder than program
synthesis
and i don't know whether it is really
historically the same
but it was considered one of the one of
the goals of artificial intelligence
to enable computers to generate their
own programs
that's a very good point i think the
original
idea was by church but of course you
know automatic programming i guess there
was
there was a lot of work on automatic
programming in 60s and 70s
and then uh in the 80s there was a lot
of work on inductive logic programming
and all of that can be viewed as
program synthesis so yeah so this is not
a complete history so this is kind of
uh you know just a starting point and
so within ai within software engineering
uh so in many fields uh program
synthesis
in different forms has been viewed as
like a
holy grail and it's uh
but i think that's a good thing so this
seems like hey you know something that
people
uh desire that the technology should be
there yeah
so i guess rojita has a question for you
already
no i also just wanted to follow up on
that that
i actually did ages ago read uh
automatic programming paper
and i think it was even a different i
mean it was
just one of the sub goals that
what the future should bring and i
recall
uh that we tried to it was actually
about uh
simple sorting algorithm if i decode
properly and uh
uh funny enough is that we found that
there was some
error in the quantifiers i think the
quad
quantifiers were supposed to be at the
wrong uh uh
wrong position i did that with perfect
weiner our previous speaker
and uh what is interesting is at that
time
they were already using existing tool
that was called
qa3 uh that was at sri
and uh i think that they didn't manage
to synthesize although it was a very
simple algorithm
another question was like when ben and i
were asking ourselves what
was it because of this error in the
quantifiers
or was it indeed because at that time uh
even simple sorting algorithms were out
of the reach
in of the tools so just another comment
thank you yeah thanks you just got
there is a rich history but i this
actually is a good
uh point for me to say one thing is that
if you look at more classical work on
program synthesis it was focused on
things like sorting
algorithm that was sorting was
considered like as a test case can you
can you synthesize like this different
sorting algorithms and the specification
of a sorting algorithm is clear
i i think in the current version of
synthesis
we do not ex i don't think that's the
focus
i think we are looking at more practical
uses and
you know the the ones that i mentioned
like you know can end users synthesize
a sql query from uh giving a few
examples
i think that's a maybe more modest but
it's
also more relevant i think it's it's not
clear who wants to actually synthesize
a sorting algorithm
so the so i think there is a shift in
focus
and that has helped okay but this was
great
discussion so let me actually continue
so before you go
rajiv there is one more question for
supratik he raised his hand so let's
give him a chance again
yeah quick question is that when you say
the set of expressions which form the
syntactic guidance
so we are including
loopy programs programs with loops also
as part of that or
uh it's uh it's a good question i think
it will become clear
when we yeah let me actually
yeah so uh so what what i talked about
was more like
motivation and giving you different uh
examples
uh where this syntax guided synthesis
shows up
but let me now make uh the question more
formal uh particularly for this audience
i think this would be
the right thing to do so uh so
intuitively it's you know we have a set
of
programs actually i think calling them
programs is a bit
misleading these are more like uh
expressions or program
snippets and that's the syntactic
constraint
and then i have a logical specification
which is a semantic constraint right
and uh what we want to
do is uh formalize this on top of
uh smt infrastructure so i think in
in this workshop series there is also a
workshop on saturn smt so many of you
must be familiar with it but just for
those who
are not super familiar with smt here is
like one slide summary
so smt stands for satisfiability modulo
theories
and the core computational problem is
given a logical formula
uh check if it's satisfiable uh so
uh uh the the formulas that we are
looking for
usually have not just booleans but
bit vectors and integers and more
complex
types and modular theories
uh refers to the fact that the
interpretation for
these additional symbols for example if
i'm using
integers i the formula may involve
addition multiplication
and so on the interpretation for those
symbols
is fixed right so we are looking for a
satisfying model
where the the model satisfies some
constraints of the underlying theory so
in the case of integers it would be the
linear
say if you have a linear arithmetic then
it would be
the interpretation given by linear
arithmetic to symbols such as addition
so this has become a a
a major breakthrough in computer science
designing
uh efficient solvers uh
to check formulas for these different
smp theories
and so we we thought that we should
build our
framework the the standardization of
this syntax guided synthesis problem on
top of that right
so uh so a number of
technologies contribute to smt so
satisfiability solver sat is one
but linear arithmetic uh there is a
particular
nice construction for being congruent
closure and the combination of these
actually give you very efficient smts on
this right
so uh so with that background now i can
actually define
this cyrus problem formally so you fix a
background theory
so you know it could be linear integer
arithmetic so that fixes what kind
of what types of variables are allowed
and what operations on these
variables are allowed then you specify
the function that's to be synthesized
so you know you may say okay i want f of
the type in cross into int
so in general there could be multiple
functions but for the purpose of this
talk let's
assume we have only one and then the
input to the scigus problem consists of
two things
so one is the specification that's the
logical constraint or semantic
constraint
and it's a formula uh that involves
symbols in this underlying theory and
the symbol f
that's the one that you are trying to
synthesize right
so if you know about smt then uh
this f is not an uninterpreted symbol
it's
really the function that you want to
synthesize right and of course
there could be uninterpreted symbols
because the underlying theory could be
uh you know the theory with
uninterpreted functions
and then the set of expressions so
that's the candidate
uh uh that's the space of candidate
implementations that you are going to
search through
and that's given by context free grammar
so we are assuming that context free
grammars people are very familiar with
uh anyone working in this space will be
familiar with
smt and that's the extra
uh technical stuff that you need to know
to
generate these cygas problems that's
relatively limited
and then the computational problem is
now is precise
so you find you want to find an
expression
a small e in this set capital e
specified by the context-free grammar
such that if you take the smp formula
which is given as a logical spec and
substitute this expression
e for the symbol f then what you get is
valid
it it's it should hold for all inputs
and this appeared in a paper uh
in fm cad 2013 as part of this escape
project
uh with a number of people including uh
you know raspberry who is
here and sanjit sesha and
armando solar and a number of students
so just to give you an example so so
suppose i fix the theory to be
qflia so in this is kind of uh
smt lingo but basically it means
quantifier free formulas in linear
integer arithmetic where you
the types are integers and booleans and
you have logical connectives
conditionals
and uh and then you say that okay the
function
that's to be synthesized is f which
takes two inputs
x1 and x2 of type in and returns end
and the specification says that x1
is less than or equal to the output of f
and x2 is
is less than or equal to output of f
that is f should compute a value which
is greater than or equal to both
its inputs so this does not fix the
f uniquely but that's the computational
problem find
f and presumably the simplest f
with uh you know with uh with this
which satisfies this specification and
but
the the the nice thing about sagas is
that you can also specify the grammar
separately right so suppose uh uh
i want to see if a linear expression can
f be constructed as a linear expression
then uh then i can specify the following
grammar which is
the desired f is either the inputs or a
constant or some are
difference of expressions right so this
is a precise specification of this
syntactic space
and if you think about it that uh
if i want f to be
such that it's greater than or equal to
both its inputs
and uh the only constructs that i have
is like are just addition and
subtraction
then in fact no such f exists i mean
no matter what linear combination of x1
and x2 you construct you can't guarantee
that it's always will be greater than or
equal to both x1 and x2
so then i can go and say that okay can i
find something with conditionals right
yeah with if then
else where the con but now i want
to see if the expressions uh without
addition can i find an implementation
that uses conditionals but not addition
and in this specific case uh
it turns out indeed there is such a
solution
which basically says if x1 is less than
or equal to x 2 then x 2
l 6 1. so this is really max max of
x 1 and x 2 if you think about the
specification
so it's it's not specifying a function
uniquely but max
of x1 and x2 definitely satisfies the
spec
to compute max you need conditional you
don't need
addition and by varying the syntactic
space
you can control the search space
and you can also control what type of
solution that you want right
and the current cycle solvers then can
you know it can
generate this
uh so this is how the uh
you know the syntax looks like so in smt
the standardized format is called
smt lib and uh the format that we have
it's called synth lib
it looks very much like a smt lib with
some
some extensions so the set logic li
says that okay the underlying logic is
linear integer arithmetic
this synth fun is a new keyword which is
special to these
uh to the synthesis part and it says
that
it declares max2 to be in the
declarations type and then it
has the grammar and then you have
the constraints are the constraints on
the desired max2 and this checksynth
command then says that synthesize a
function
max2 which satisfies these constraints
right yeah
so of course yeah we don't need to focus
on the details of the syntax
i wanted to show you this to just
suggest
that it blends with smt lip
nicely and uh now actually andrew
reynolds who
is who maintains smp
lip very actively he has gotten involved
in uh
zygus and synthlib and he has made sure
that
the current versions of smt lib
and the zygus formats are all in
compliance
they all match uh so
i had mentioned four different problems
uh so let uh
uh so in interest of time i'm just going
to
focus on one of them how to formalize it
exactly uh
as a zygous problem so let's suppose i
want to find
inductive loop in variance automatically
and here is kind of a sketch of
some uh potential program has
six variables xyz that are boolean abc
are
integers and there is some test so it
has a single loop
and some loop body and there is some
precondition than a post condition
and the goal is to find an inductive
invariant so that
the proof goes through right and i i
want to set up
the question of generating the
invariance as a cyrus problem
so first we have to declare the function
to be synthesized so let's call it inf
and this is suppose i want to say that
the
uh the desired invariant involves only x
z a b then i can declare this as a type
saying that
okay it takes x z a b and returns a
booth invariant is a
you know it's a boolean it's a predicate
so it's output type is booth
and it takes only four things so it's
like giving a hint to the synthesizer
that
the desired invariant instead of
involving all the six program variables
involves only these four right
uh then uh to generate a logical
constraint we need to compile the loop
body into
a logical formula and assuming this loop
body does didn't
itself doesn't have internal loops we
can
compile it into a formula so this is a
standard
verification technology now so like
generating verification conditions
so this update is going to be a formula
that involves the old program variables
and fresh copies which will reflect the
updated values of all these variables so
it's a
formula between old variables and
updated variables
and now the specification of the desired
function
inf can be that
the precondition implies if if n is
satisfied and test
fails then the post condition should be
satisfied
and if in is satisfied so and
if we update the variables according to
the formula update
and the updated variable satisfied test
so the test primes refers to that
then the updated variable should satisfy
the invader so that's like saying that
the invariant is
inductive in uh through one execution of
the loop
right and now and then we can
uh we want to synthesize certain and
the syntax guidance can be provided by
defining the template for these what
kind of in
that we want right and so for example if
i want to say that
it's uh uh it should involve
conditionals
and uh linear arithmetic then i specify
the grammar for n
right uh i i could specify for example
that in
involves only four conjuncts well i can
specify
something like that so this is how you
can go from
template guided invariant generation to
this
and a number of benchmarks from the
uh these software verification
competition that's usually held
with etaps have been translated to get a
whole bunch of
benchmarks for cyclists and and then the
benefit is that now you can actually
focus on the core computational
problem of how to search through the
space of all potential invariants
without worrying about a lot of
front-end details
and if if you were looking at
programming by examples
then the template would actually specify
the grammar of the
uh expressions that you are looking for
and then the specification there would
be much easier it would just say that
the
on the given if i had five input output
examples it would just say that
hand over all those five examples on
that specific input the output should be
the desired one
but usually we can also augment the
specification by adding some integrity
constraints if we know that if there are
some
logical uh constraints that the
uh all you know all
programs should satisfy then
you could add that to the specification
so some domain specific knowledge could
be built
into the specification and that's what
we will typically do in pbe
and uh in the second half of this uh
talk actually i want to give you a a
specific application related to
uh uh synthesizing network traffic
classifiers and we'll get
back to this at that point
uh so so that was like the formal
definition of uh
scigirls and the in the next part i want
to talk about
uh some solution strategies for cyclists
but this again would be a good time to
take some questions
so any questions because this is a good
time because then
actually after the questions i think we
we could take a short
break uh let's say five
to ten minutes oh
you know get it and then
other questions if questions please
raise your hand
yes maria do you have a question
i'm seeing you working yes thank you
could you please could you please just
go back
to the slide to the page where you
introduced the
the paradigm for uh syntax guided
exactly this this one exactly that the
complete
exactly um so fix the background theory
function to be synthesized general case
multiple function and then we have
specification type formula
the set e and computational problem okay
but then thank you very much but then
all the other problems you enumerated
later
namely find inductive loop invariant
automatically function to be synthesized
compile the body etc etc
um i'm sorry but i didn't see all the
connections so are they
all instances of the general
uh syntax guided synthesis problem
are they are sub components
of the of the syntax guided sim to this
problem
uh the format so the you know
so for example here if yeah let me go
back to this inductive invariant thing
right so the uh so
so given a program i want to synthesize
invariant and what i what's uh
saying that this question can be
formalized exactly as a cybers problem
so what's the underlying theory well
depends on what kinds of invariance you
are looking for so you
say that okay i want my invariant to be
say a linear expression so you would
pick l i a to be the theory
the the unknown function is in and
so instead of having all program
variables involved in
m i could change its input type to
restrict the search space which is more
like a hint
would say that okay the invariant in
this case instead of all these six
variables involves only four
the output type of desired invisible
then uh this compilation step is
automatic
and then this is the logical formula
which says that you know pre implies in
in and not test implies post and in an
update and test trend implies in
prime so this is really specification of
what it means for
in to be an inductive invariant that's
strong enough to prove
the correctness of the program and the
syntactic guidance comes from which
template do you pick
right so the uh so yeah so the
uh that's uh you know that's what's
going to be
so this this question then can be
translated to something like this
and so we have a whole bunch of
benchmarks where
questions about automatic generation of
invariants for c programs from this
software verification con
you know competition they all get
compiled into something that looks like
this
and the unknown function there so here
in this example was max2 there it would
be the invariant for that specific
program
and these constraints would then capture
the i guess the
the update functions for those specific
programs
so the so i didn't go through the other
examples yeah but programming by example
or you know program repair and so on
they they all can be
formulated exactly in this framework
so so there is work on uh so maybe you
know so i think this
uh uh uh yeah let me
just show you one thing before we take a
break
yeah so i think it's going to look like
this that
so this is the intermediate format
and then you know the invariant
generation so there would be a front end
which takes your program
and then compiles the uh the problem of
generating
the desired invariant into something
that looks in our
format and then the programming by
examples also could be compiled into
uh instances of this uh synthetic
and so then the people who are working
on these back-ends could just focus
on how best to optimize the search
and the this uh cyclist could be used
for some other applications besides
these four
that i have shown
so does this answer uh your question
maria
oh yes thank you very much okay thank
you
so super attic has also a question
you want to go here yeah hi rajiv so
when can you go to the slide on
invariant generation yeah
yeah yeah thank you so uh
how is this different from uh you know
constrained on clause uh
solving and this looks very similar
right i mean is it just in the syntactic
template
that yes yeah definitely
the you know it is uh the
uh yeah i mean it's it's a specific
formalization of it
and then you know using home clauses
would be a different formalization
here the key is really the syntactic
template
and you can vary it and
you could i think in many other
approaches maybe the syntactic template
is implicit here it's an explicit input
and you can change it
okay but the syntactic template is an
input to the uh you know to the
synthesis routine
that's key right so it's generic it's
it's uh in some sense the way
synthesis works is uh is
it's it's not tuned to a specific
template it takes the template
part of me it's not due to a specific
word no it's uh the template is an input
to the sagas problem
yeah yeah so yeah so you know this the
it's just another
right so this synthesis uh problem has
two inputs the logical specification and
then the template specified using
context regardless
and you want a synthesis uh tool to work
for
no matter what what the input grammar is
and what the
input specification okay thank you
all right so let's take one more
question and uh before we go to the
break so mark has a question
do you want to i yeah so it's just
wondering
we have the invariant generation we can
also
synthesize program expressions do we
have a way of
synthesizing both the loops themselves
and the looped bodies at the same time
is that something that that's a good
question
well in theory you can i mean you can
formalize it the question is will it uh
work right yeah so the our current
benchmarks don't
uh involve such more ambitious thank you
all right then uh i think we should
take uh 10 minutes break so it's now
30. uh in vienna
so anyway it's uh it's past half past
so let's uh meet that uh 40 past
is that fine with you rajiv or should we
yeah yeah
all right all right so let's take a 10
minute break for coffee
all right see you later guys
you
so
so
this
so i guess we can talk later rajiv about
this but uh
i think it's interesting what is the
nesting depth that you can get in these
or the expressions that we can actually
synthesize with the existing solvers
yeah yeah so the s yeah i guess it could
be about 100 asp nodes
so i don't yeah because in the end you
are
synthesizing an expression and the
expression is specific you know it's
represented by its abstract syntax tree
so it's hierarchical in some sense so
you you can explain what you have
synthesized
pretty well yeah oh yeah interpretable
actually yes uh uh
yeah i think i have some examples for
this network traffic
all right so we are going to start like
in one minute
now
but that's a huge advantage i mean
compared to
let's say the neural networks where they
have no idea
synthesized so in fact yeah i think this
network traffic classification
i want to get to that because that's an
area where people were using machine
learning but
so this could be a solution yeah
all right so uh welcome everybody back
so
let's continue with the second part so
rajiv your floor
it's yours uh thank you radio
so yeah so i told you about how to
formalize the problem and now
let me give you a brief idea about how
do we actually solve
this problem right uh so this actually
relates a bit to the question that
suprathick asked that it's saigons
are same as solving smt formulas with
quantifier alternation right
and the answer is not always so if the
set of expressions
is say only linear expressions right so
if i have two input variables x and y
then any linear expression over these
input variables will be of the form
a x plus b y plus c so then we are
so we we can capture the set of uh in an
arbitrary expression with just three
parameters abc
and then i can reduce uh the desired
search to solving the
quantified formula exists abc for all x
some spec hopes right but if i don't
know
uh uh the depth of the tree
right the search tree and not every not
always
an arbitrary tree can be captured by
a small set of parameters then you know
you can't really reduce cybers to
this quantif uh you know quantified smt
formulas right and the
but there is another reason to focus on
this problem because this syntactic
structure
that the that we have in the set of
candidate implementations that can be
used effectively
by the solver and surprisingly in fact
now uh the latest solvers for quantified
smt
uh and we did not expect this when we
started this project
in fact youth cyber so if you think of a
a formula such as for all x there exists
a y
something something so finding this y is
actually
uh some function of x and you know what
what we would call as this column
function
in logic so i can actually use syntactic
guidance
to limit the space of school and
functions over which you are searching
for
so the new approaches to solving
quantified smt
in fact formula formalize it as a
science problem so that's
uh that's an interesting
uh direction uh but let me tell you
about how do we actually solve cycles
and
so you can think of cygas as an active
learning problem so there is a search
algorithm
which is looking for candidate
expressions and the verification oracle
checks if the candidate expression
synthesized by the search algorithm
meets the specification
and if it does if it does then it can
stop if it doesn't it produces
a counter example and the way this works
is that the search algorithm starts with
some initial examples or initial outputs
uh initial input sorry and when the
verification
oracle says that the candidate
expression doesn't satisfy
the spec it generates a counter example
which is added to the
set i and this can be best be understood
with this little example
and this technique is called counter
example guided inductive synthesis
uh sieges for short uh originally
proposed
in uh by armando solar le zama and has
kind of
become the standard technique for most
of the cyber solvers
and here is the specification that we
looked at earlier
that f should be greater than or equal
to both its inputs right
and for these for this part uh let's
assume that the set
e of expressions is built from
the input variables x 1 x 2 constants 0
1
and say comparison and if then
initially the set i which is the set of
interesting
inputs it's initialized to the empty set
and
the goal of the search algorithm is to
find a candidate
implementation for f from this space of
expressions
such that f works f
at least for the inputs in i well
initially
i is empty so in fact any f would work
for an empty set of inputs and so it may
generate
x1 like a simplest expression an
expression of size one
and so let's assume that it it returns
x1
so what it's saying is that x1
is a potential implementation for the of
for the desired function f and this
works for the inputs in
i and the job of the verification oracle
is to
plug in x1 for f in the specification
and see does it work for all x1 and x2
and this check fails and it returns a
counter example and says that
oh if you set f to x1 for the input
x1 0 and x 2 equal to 1 the spec won't
be satisfied
because in this case you know the uh f
would return 0 and
it's not greater than or equal to x 2
which is 1 in this case
and now the search algorithm tries to
find an f
which works for this one specific input
zero comma one and in this so it tries
to find the simplest
implementation of f which works for all
inputs in the set i
which currently just holds exactly one
input
and it may return x2 as a candidate
implementation
and the verification checks again the
same thing it says
uh setting f to x2 will it work for
uh will the specification hold for all x
1 x 2 and the answer is no
in particular it wouldn't work for x 1
is 1
and x 2 is 0. and
then the and this process then continues
uh
maybe after another iteration the the
set i contains
four examples zero one one zero zero
zero one one
and for these four inputs the
uh so now the search algorithm is
restricting its attention to these four
inputs and trying to find an f which
works on
for these four inputs and then it
actually has to generalize and the
implementation that it comes up with is
if x1 is less than or equal to x2 then
x2 l61
and then the verifier checks that
setting f to this expression
does it work for all x1 x2 and in fact
in this case it will conclude that
the if we have generalized enough and
the the process will stop
so why is this good so the uh like
what's the benefit of sages so actually
let me
show show it to you as an algorithm and
then
it will become clear so
uh our goal is to find an f in
a set capital e such that for all
x in the domain of in the domain of
inputs
the spec holes so there are two
exponential searches here you know
finding f
and then you know checking that for all
x something holds
and so for the sake of argument let's
assume both of these are exponentially
large search spaces so the thing is
even though we have made so much
progress in sat searching through an
exponential
space is hard the cases where it works
is when uh you know when you find a
solution you can terminate
early so this for all x quantifier is
kind of challenging if i said that find
an x for which something holds that
satisfiability
so even though the space is exponential
sat and smt solvers work quite well
when you can terminate early and
this architecture of sieges has
basically
helped us set up two independent
collaborating
exponential searches all of
them can terminate early so we set
i to the empty set and what we
what we are trying to do in learning
phase is find an f
which works for all x and i but now it's
it's not really a universal quantifier
it's just a conjunction because the set
i is
finite it's it's actually small so the
so the interesting search here is only
finding an f and the moment we find an f
which works for all the current
uh interesting inputs this search can
stop
and then the verification phase is
actually trying to
show that the f that the learner has
learned
is that doesn't work for some input so
it's really
looking for an x for which this uh
using the current f the spec does not
hold
and this uh you know this can be given
to a satisfiability solver or an smt
solver
and that that works fast so the only
time
you are forced to search through all xs
is upon termination right when you you
have found
the right f and then you it would have
to look for all
uh it would have to search through all
x's right
so so in some sense the universal
quantifier gets applied
only once even though this is an
iterative process right
if if you look at the original question
is there an f such that for all x
well every for every f if you try to
apply that for all x search then that's
going to be very expensive
and that's why this sieges seems to work
quite well in practice
uh so the uh so there are three
search strategies so when we started
this work one was
for learning so for verification we are
just going to use an
off-the-shelf smt solver but for
learning or for searching
we need a new strategies and
there were three strategies enumerative
symbolic and stochastic
in interest of time i'm just going to
show you the first one enumerative and
just give you a flavor of what it does
and this was first in a paper we had
in pldi in 2013
so what's the specification for the
enumerative search so i have some
finite set of inputs i have a grammar
that's generating
a set of candidate implementations and i
have a specification
and i'm searching for an expression
which works at least for the inputs
in this finite set r and the first
attempt
is just let's just start enumerating
these expressions in this set capital e
in increasing size till you find
something
uh that mean that satisfies the spec for
all inputs in height
so of course this is you know this is
too prohibitive but
but remember that since the set i is
small
uh if you if you look at a specific
expression
checking whether it satisfies the spec
for all inputs in i
can be done very fast right so what we
want to do is actually prune this search
and
uh try to find techniques so that we
don't have to look at all expressions
and the and then an improvement of this
attempt and actually this works quite
well and later we will see some more
optimizations of this is on this idea of
equivalence of expressions so let's
declare two expressions even and e2 to
be
equivalent if they give the same answer
on all x's in the current set capital i
of interesting inputs
and so initially i is empty and you know
as as these iterations go i i will have
a few inputs so in general actually this
uh
lots and lots of expressions will be
considered equivalent because we are
looking only at
x's in this small sector and the key
idea in pruning
is that if when lot of expressions are
equivalent
let's just use one of them for our
search it's some canonical
representative
and not only discard these other
equivalent expressions
but when we build more complex
expressions
we want when we need a sub expression we
are just going to
focus on these representative
expressions
and let me illustrate this with an
example so let's suppose
my spec is f is greater than
both its input so i've modified it from
the previous example
for illustrating the specific pruning
and let's suppose my grammar is says
that
it's either one of the inputs or the
constants 0 1 or
the sum of expressions and let us assume
for now that i is this consists of a
single point 0 comma 1
then we are looking for an expression
generated by this grammar
which works for uh you know the the
specific input
so how would the enumerative search go
well it will first
enumerate all four expressions of size 1
in this case it's x 1 x 2 0 and 1.
so the key idea in pruning is to check
are any of these expressions
equivalent with respect to this specific
input x 1 and 0 and x 2 equal to 1
and you would realize that oh in this
case 0 is equivalent to
x1 and 1 is equivalent to x2 but the
expressions x1 and x2 are distinct
even on even on the specification but
they are distinguishable
right so instead of having four
expressions of size one now i have only
two expressions of size one
and furthermore this actually bootstraps
now
i want to generate expressions of larger
size so you know
for this grammar or you know there could
be so the relevant rule will be e plus e
or e can expand into well there are four
expressions of size one but now there
are only two
that are inequality and i'm going to
focus only on these representatives
and the second e here can will also
expand into either x 1 and x 2.
so instead of getting 16 possible
expressions of size 3
i get only 4 expressions of size 3. and
again i check are any of these
equivalent to the ones that we already
have on this specific input
0 comma 1 and we are going to discard
these
and so the only one that will be left is
x 2 plus x 2.
so now i have only three expressions of
size three
and then as we go along we are going to
check if
any of them satisfies the specification
and stop the movement one of them works
right and so this simple idea well one
has to do some algorithm engineering to
implement it efficiently
but this actually gives us lot of
savings
and this is the basic idea in
enumerative search
so in the interest of time i'm going to
skip over symbolic search and there is
also
stochastic search and uh
but i will post these slides if anyone
is interested in
uh but this uh so this but just to give
you a flavor of how the search works
so with uh uh so with that uh so
so in this original paper in fm cad 2013
we implemented
these three search strategies and
evaluated them
on some set of benchmarks actually at
that time the conventional wisdom was
that the
the symbolic search would do best and uh
the but in fact this experiment showed
that the enumerate research in fact does
better
and the motivation for setting up the
standardized format
and the competition was actually the
success story of smp
where once uh the smt lib format was
standardized and
a variety of problems were collected and
benchmarks were collected
and an annual competition was set up uh
you know tools like cvc4 and c3
kept on improving the back-end
technology and
a number of tools for verification for
testing
of uh used uh you use this interchange
format
to uh focus more on the front end so
it's actually units so if
if you want to verify let's say c
programs lot of action is really at the
front end
and the constraint solving at back end
is of course important
but if i can use it as a black box
technology
then uh you know the work in a tool like
cbmc which is
a bounded model checking tools for c
would be much more
uh facilitated so that's
so based on that smt success story we
said let's set up a cyclist competition
and it's been held for four or five
years now
and the the driving applications were
like program optimization and program
repair that we talked about
and we implemented a number of these
search techniques
so how have things evolved so i'm just
going to give you a flavor so
currently we have about 2 000 benchmarks
uh collected from you know different
applications there are some special
tracks so you know programming by
examples
so the spec is of a particular format so
some tools exploit that
uh if when the grammar is conditional
linear arithmetic one can try to exploit
the properties of linear arithmetic and
so that's why that's also a special
track
and over the years some new solutions
strategies and applications have uh
shown up so let me just illustrate one
new solution strategy just just as an
illustrative
thing and it fits well with the
enumerative search that i talked about
so let's go back to this specification
of
max2 that we had that the output of f
should be greater than or equal to
both the inputs x1 and x2 and the
solution was
uh if x1 is less than or equal to x2
then x2 x1
well this is not a complex expression
and we can easily
the current synthesis tools can easily
generate this
but uh even in this case observe that
the uh the size of the expression is
much larger than
the sub expressions x2 and x1 which are
of size one
so actually if you think of x2 and x1 as
partial solutions they cover they cover
the space of all inputs
and so this suggests a different
approach to enumerative search by
applying
uh divide and conquer techniques and
there is a very nice
uh analogy and not just on the knowledge
it's based on
decision tree learning and we will see
that connection in a minute right
so that but at the high level the core
idea
is that generate partial solutions that
are correct on subsets of inputs
and then combine them using conditions
right so for this purpose you you will
have to enumerate terms
and tests for conditionals separately
right
so but to see the connection to decision
tree learning let's go back to
uh you know the the enumeration strategy
so we were enumerating expressions like
x1 x2
x2 plus x2 and so on with pruning it
so so the pruning allowed us not to
consider all
expressions of size 1 but only a
representative ones
on the given set of inputs right but
suppose the current inputs so suppose i
had inputs like 0 1 and 1 0 so i'll have
a few inputs
so you can think of inputs as data
points
and expressions as labels and this edges
says
that oh the expression x1 satisfies the
specification
for the input one comma zero right so
this
so this i can think of x1 as labeling
the data point right so the data points
are these interesting inputs generated
by the cgs loop
and the expressions are the ones that
are labels enumerated by the enumerative
search
and uh so previous algorithm
searched for an expression that
was correct for all inputs but now we
could
stop when we have enough coverage
that is every input
is correct for at least one of the
expressions
right and we can now
enumerate predicates separately and you
can think of these as
attributes right so you can think of the
decision tree that you want to learn
will have uh the data you know the
uh the express the the labels at the
leaves
and the attributes at the internal nodes
because these would be our predicate
and the precise definition is that an
input
has an attribute p if you know the
p p of x whole so for example the
input 0 comma 1 is
the expressions x 2 and x 2 plus 2 are
both correct for this input
and this data point satisfies the
attribute x 1 less than or equal to x 2.
so now we can enumerate expressions till
we get
coverage of all the inputs then we cover
then we enumerate predicates and then we
apply a standard decision tree learning
algorithm
to compute an expression whose uh
internal nodes will be labeled with
attributes and the leaves will be
labeled with labels which would be the
expressions and then that will give us
uh the desired expression and this gives
actually
a a significant speed up
uh there's another technique where you
can
try to learn probabilistic models but in
the interest of time let me skip that
so just to give you a flavor of uh
what kinds of things we can handle so
this is this slide is slightly old so
this is actually from 2017 competition
where we had about 1500 benchmarks
uh so at that
point so depending on the space so for
the string manipulation programs the
resulting
expressions had about 20 ast notes
whereas for bit vector manipulation
programs
it we could synthesize expressions with
1000 asd notes
so this is a computationally hard
problem so depending
on you know the the the class of
benchmarks or even the specific
benchmarks the
computation time could vary a lot um
we had a number of participating solvers
that year and this euphemi
thing which actually i didn't talk about
which combined decision trees with learn
probabilistic models was the best solver
right
and the typical uh time to synthesize
uh you know things expressions of this
size was about few minutes the the
current winner is actually cvc4 but
developed by andrew reynolds and his
team
so basically cvc4 is a very uh
robust and standard smt solver and what
they did
was uh a number of these uh enumerative
search strategies in particular this
pruning based on expression equivalence
was integrated
inside cvc4 itself so we were
we were treating the verification oracle
as a black box but there is obviously no
need for that you know
the two could be tightly integrated and
uh
so in 2019 cbc4 was the winner and in
fact it was
uh its performance was so much better
than other solvers that in 2020 we did
not find
entries which were even competitive so
the competition was not held so to have
a kind of the next evolution or next
step
we need something better you know that
that beats the current cvc4
uh a number of new interesting
applications have come up and i'm just
going to tell you a little bit about the
synthesis of cryptocircuits because it's
quite cool
and uh this application came around
after we developed the scigirls solvers
so
we are particularly proud of that
and it was done in chao wang who is at
usc in his group and
it appeared in this paper in cap 2016.
so and it was kind of unexpected uh sort
of
fixing circuits against timing attacks
so here is a cryptographic circuit where
you know you have some inputs
uh and then you have some outputs and
this is a real circuit it's from this
advanced encryption system uh aess box
implementation
first published in 2002 and
so the goal of this circuit is that some
of the inputs are public and some are
private
and the goal is that if we change the
public inputs which may be
encoding say a public key and if you
observe the outputs
you won't be able to infer anything
about private inputs
and this circuit does satisfy that
property logically
but there is a side channel attack uh if
if i if i change a public input bit and
if i can measure
how long it takes for some output to
change and if i
do these experiments repeatedly i will
be able to infer something about
the private inputs
based on timing characteristics and the
high level idea here is that if you
for example if you look at this out and
gate then you know there is one input
which fits
immediately to the end whereas some
other input feeds through a long chain
of and gates
and if the and gets output changes from
say
uh one to zero you you'll be able
quickly you will be able to infer
something about these two different
classes of inputs right so that's the
basic idea in the side channel attack
and this uh vulnerability was reported
uh in 2014 in this paper in date
and they said okay let's build a
a resilient circuit and the basic idea
if you look at the structure of this fix
here
is to make that all
parts to have exactly the same delays by
adding these
dummy buffers right and this resulting
circuit
is functionally equivalent to the
original one
and has this property that it's constant
time the length
uh the the path lengths from every input
to every output is exactly the same
so uh so java banks group had this
clever idea that
they said okay let's set this up as a
synthesis problem
uh to finding an attack resilient
circuit and in fact
uh as a zygos problem so what's the
precise specification so
given a circuit c you want to
automatically synthesize a circuit c
prime such that c prime is functionally
equivalent to c
so that's a semantic constraint and in
fact can be written in sat
you don't even need smt and all input
output paths in c
prime have same length and this is a
syntactic constraint
right so if you think about the parse
tree of the circuit
you know the without knowing what the
actual elements are if i said that all
all parts are of same length well of
course you you need some bound on the
path length but about
that bound is uh the the max path length
in c itself
so you generate you write this grammar
saying okay you know these non-terminals
are generating
uh circuits with path length one these
non terminals are generating circuits
with path line two and so on right and
you
go up to path length say five for
example in this case
and the the one thing to note here is
that
even though there has been a lot of
progress in eda tools
uh you can't really set this up as a
synthesis question because they are
typically tailored to
optimizing say timing or optimizing
area or something like that and usually
they spend a lot of effort
in up in developing
uh optimizing for some specific measure
but now it's like a generic
syntactic constraint and you can just
give it to
saiger solver and the surprisingly
it actually gives you a very uh
non-intuitive and very compact circuit
which is shown here
so the so it's fun it's guaranteed to be
functionally equivalent to the original
circuit
and it's constant time so it's at least
resilient to the specific kind of timing
attack
and if you compare it to the handcrafted
attack resilient circuit reported in
this paper
you can see that you know it's it has
much better
quality because has fewer gates and
fewer path lengths
and it's also generated automatically
so this is an example where the
infrastructure we built actually helped
and uh but uh but let me actually spend
next 10 minutes and then we will go to
discussion about future directions
about some application we did very
recently and i think this
is uh there is a lot of potential here
so i want to tell you about this
and it's kind of a bittersweet because
we couldn't use the existing science
infrastructure though a lot of ideas
were useful
and this is reported in a paper in
upcoming takas and it's for network
traffic classification
so what's the uh application here
so you know in the network switch you
have a stream of packets and the switch
is deciding whether to drop the packet
or whether to alert a controller and so
on right
and uh so this network traffic
engineering is a big field where
people want to detect attacks so an
example attack could
be what's called ddos so it's a denial
of service attack and it's a flood
attack
which basically says that uh you know
some
uh ip addresses in certain range
are opening lots of connections or you
know could be tcp connections
within a short time window so as to
exhaust the resources
at this server
so uh so that this has a clear pattern
right you want to count how many
connections are open
are they from kind of similar ip
addresses they have to be within a short
time interval
but you also need to know you know
what's the
uh you know what's what's an open
session so it requires some kind of
pattern matching over the
traffic so
uh so this uh actually it's a great
opportunity for synthesis
that if i gave you positive and negative
examples so if i said oh you know here
is kind of a new problem
so today's attack you know the server is
exhausted you know so it must be some
new attack which i don't know about
and uh this uh so today's traffic looks
quite different from you know the
traffic of the past days so think of the
past days as the
uh the traffic from the past days as
positive examples and the traffic from
today is a negative example and find me
a classifier right
uh so compared to you know the the first
example i had used was flash fill where
the inputs were like these strings like
you know phone numbers and names and so
on
compared to that here the uh your
input example here is actually raw
network traffic which is thousands and
thousands of packets so a kind of a very
different
uh beast here uh particularly for the
anomalous traffic you have very few
examples for positive traffic actually
you have lots of examples
you want high accuracy because if you
say that oh you know
the the operator will have to examine
what you have generated
if you are giving some false reports
they would be quite annoyed
so machine people have tried to use
machine learning but one
way where program synthesis can have a
win
is that the output classifier
if it's interpretable if it's in some
domain specific language that would be
great
because then the operators can
understand it they can edit it and so on
a key requirement here is that what you
synthesize has to be implementable
efficiently on the router because the
whole point of having
to say having a classifier is to
actually run it dynamically on the
router and
uh reject the traffic which matches the
anomalous
pattern in the future right uh
and we want this to be expressive you
know so that you know there are uh
such you know this traffic has lots of
rich features you know there could be
session layers application layers and
the attacks could be at any level and
all of them should be expressible right
this is a very active
area if you are interested in what uh
machine learning based approaches
look like you know state of the approach
for this problem
i would recommend this paper from nsdi
2018 it's it's a system called kitsune
which is uh you know uses auto encoders
and you know they have lots of
these advantages except that it's not
interpretable
and what we're doing is hopefully better
right yeah
so what can the program synthesis-based
solution look like right so the first
step
is choose a suitable dsl for traffic
classifies
it so you know in the case of uh
if it's a linear integer arithmetic
generation of
template based uh invariant generation
we know what the dsl looks like you know
some combination of these linear
expressions
here this is actually a new space right
in fact
even for flash fill a lot of effort and
ingenuity
was in designing the the dsl that the
uh flash fill goes through
for synthesizing sql query is it for sql
queries but this is kind of different so
we had to work on that
so it should be expressive enough to
capture a variety of attacks
it should have built-in abstractions for
succinct descriptions
and then the second step is designer
synthesis tool which
actually finds a succinct expression in
this dsl
and it should be scalable to generate
interesting classifiers right
and the new challenge here compared to
state-of-the-art synthesis technologies
this ability to handle traffic which is
like
thousands and thousands of packets right
yeah
so the the tools that we built is called
chat engine and
the uh the dsl that we use is actually
it's called net query i'm going to skip
through these few slides because
i think this is kind of orthogonal
but we had designed uh actually a nice
dsl
called net query and this was in a
sitcom paper a couple of years ago
and you can uh the basic features of
this are actually here so it's a
it's built on top of regular expressions
but something we call quantitative
regular expressions
where regular expressions are merged
with aggregate operators like
max min sum average standard deviation
and so on like very an expressive set of
aggregates
a lot of domain specific features so
like ports ip addresses
ranges of addresses then you can
do a group by on ip address keys
so things very specific to network
traffic
references to time windows and in this
setting
the expression maps a an input traffic
to a numerical value right
so for example in that ddos attack we
wanted to count
the number of open uh tcp sessions right
so
so the expression should match uh should
map you know a network
uh trace to a to some numerical value
right and uh so in the sitcom paper we
had actually defined
this language net query for a different
purpose you know to
actually think uh thinking about
high-level programming abstractions for
network traffic engineering
and now actually we can use it for the
synthesis purpose
but as part of that effort we had
actually developed an efficient
compiler and runtime system which takes
a net query expression
and actually can run it on the switch
right
uh and the the kinds of things that you
can actually express
in this language are you know flow level
traffic measurements you know so
there are these concepts like heavy
heaters and super spreaders in network
traffic engineering so those could be
expressed
you can detect sensor attacks uh you
know aggregate
statistics over tcp connections
uh and compared to c plus plus code
this could be quite succinct so we have
we had like a complex application level
monitoring property about voiceover ip
sessions
which could be expressed with a net
query expression with 18
ast notes so well within the scope of
synthesis tools
and if you were to compile it into c
plus plus it
was like about 500 lines of scope right
so clearly we should be searching
through
a dsl and of course if you don't like
net query we could use
another dsl but it should satisfy
this should be expressive and should
allow succinct expressions
so this ddos attack right which is
synthesized
uh you know the and it's actually
synthesized by this sharingan tool
it looks like this complicated
expression uh so i don't want to go
through this because i haven't really
told you what the language is
but the stars are like regular
expression like stars
this sum is like some aggregate operator
and some base predicates here
for ex like you know checking something
about the tcp
field something about the source ip
address
and uh referring to the time since last
packet and some numerical values
so that should give you a flavor of what
the language looks like
as you can see that this whole
expression is not super complex right i
mean it's kind of cryptic
but it's not complex and
so of course there is this catch here
that a network operator
to interpret this they will have to know
this dsl
but the concepts are not uh
you know they're kind of things which
are
which typically people are used to
though the semantics is
a bit uh you know idiosyncratic
but if they understand that then they
can edit this right so they could for
example see that if the number of
open sessions is greater than four
that's the classifier that the
uh tool generated based on the given
examples
but if they understand what this is
saying they could change this threshold
from four to six for example if they
wanted to be more conservative
uh so going to the exact synthesis
question
uh you know so given a set of positive
and negative packet traces
you want to find an expression which
separates them
so each expression maps a trace to a
value so you want a separator and the
key challenges
is that you have a rich set of
constructs the
expressions involve numerical constants
so those who have worked on synthesis
tools know this
as a clear problem that you know these
handling these constants is a bit of a
problem
the pack the packet traces are long
thousands of
packets uh so even though the ideas from
optimized search for cyber solvers are
very much
relevant we don't have an smt theory for
these quantitative regular expressions
or and and and also for this net query
expression so we had to
really redesign the solver
and there are a number of
the search techniques which are special
so there is
something partial evaluation to do early
pruning
and those are optimization techniques
which go beyond
what we already knew from building cyber
solvers
so i'm running out of time so i'm going
to skip through this but
particular optimization but let me tell
you a little bit about experimental
evaluation so there is this
uh database of attacks
called cicids 2017 and it has eight
types of attacks
in particular includes this ddos attack
and then slow law is another
popular attack uh so we get actually
pretty high accuracy which is comparable
to this kitsune so you can't
beat machine learning approaches in
terms of accuracy
it's actually pretty good for both tools
but we actually synthesize these net
query programs which
can be interpreted you can edit them
you can deploy these things very
efficiently because you know we have
this
compiler and runtime systems for that
very time
and for seven out of these eight attacks
uh it took about
uh 50 minutes and for one of the attacks
it was about
300 minutes so you know
scalability still is something to be
worked on
or you know there are some things that
we cannot handle
in particular mixed attacks if the
traffic contains a mixture of two
different types of attacks
the tool kind of fails
so that's an opportunity for future work
so let me spend a few minutes to talk
about
research directions so let me skip this
you know so this is just a summary of
what i talked about
but in terms of infrastructure if you
look at uh
uh publications in cav pop
or pop-up or pldi or more and more even
in icm ml and eurips
there are lots and lots of publications
on program synthesis
many of them use cygas benchmarks some
of them use
uh sagas directly and the other two
infrastructures that i didn't talk about
but maybe the you know the synthesis uh
workshop has stocks on this like sketch
by solar lizard and rosette better like
and some of these efforts
do use it but not all and so this is
actually kind of frustrating because
i mean it basically says that you know
there is
these infrastructures have to be better
to be used more generically right
even then this network traffic
engineering example
that i told you about i mean we couldn't
use cyber solver as this
right yeah so one potential future
direction
is to uh keep this
uh hook into smt solvers but uh not make
it mandatory so maybe you know the back
end could refer to just a testing tool
or an interpreter
so that the search techniques can be
used
even when you don't have uh an smd
theory
for the objects that you are
synthesizing
so that that would i think that's
something people are talking about but
there is no
uh infrastructure for that
in terms of applications uh uh so
uh uh you know i wanted to tell you
about this
uh great effort at microsoft on
building uh a pba pbe based tools for
automating repetitive code
transformation so they have a tool
called blue pencil and i just heard
talk about that last week and it's just
awesome like you have this
program development environment if where
if a programmer makes some change then
you use
uh as an example the old version and the
new version that you did
as an example and you you apply this as
a coded
to the rest of the code right and
so these examples are generated
automatically based on what the
programmer is doing
and the underlying technology is exactly
the
you know the pbe the synthesis
technology for pbe
and it's integrated in this great
infrastructure and that seems to be
working very well
uh for super optimization kind of
applications i think there is this new
effort on machine programming at
intel and the the motivation there is to
porting code
to heterogeneous platforms uh
the the skype-like efforts and we are
also now looking at
how to synthesize data log programs so
going from data to logic i think that's
that's uh that's an um there is more
potential there
and finally in terms of solution
techniques uh
you know so this is uh you know making
synthesis scalable
is kind of uh you know it's an uphill
battle
and we can't expect magic bullets but
there is a steady progress being
made but applying machine learning is
obviously a you know an
ex interesting research direction
uh so how so one key challenge there is
how do you represent co
and there's lots and lots of papers on
that if you are interested here is an
example
of paper uh so learning graph
transformations to detect and fix bugs
in programs
so doing program synthesis but using
machine learning
or using graph neural networks it's a
paper in
iclear 2020 but it's just a one
representative paper
so let me stop here and take questions
in the
remaining five minutes
please yeah hi um
this is extremely interesting framework
from tacos 2021 but
first i would like to ask a couple of
questions about uh
search the enumerative search
so when you when you talked about the
numerative search
let's say if we have specification and
then the specification
changed only that slightly
do we have to do the whole search from
the beginning or can we
somehow leverage what we already pruned
or some kind of
search that we already achieved oh great
question i think
we don't know how to do that well so in
fact uh
the the uh you know
the even in some cases even as the set
of inputs changes
we have to redo the whole thing so it's
in fact the specification hasn't changed
but in the cgs loop the set of
interesting examples have changed
so the you would think that you can
reuse things from the past
but because of this pruning that we have
done based on equivalence of expressions
which is
tailored to the the current set of
interesting inputs
that gets resected i mean that
equivalence gets destroyed and so that's
a challenge
it's uh yeah i mean you know i think
there are opportunities there
uh it's uh
it's hard to come up with tools that
actually beat
the current in the current uh state of
the art yeah
right let's see an interesting direction
yeah
i see um one more question if i may
about
the representation there's a decision
tree learning yeah so this is also very
interesting approach
and you said that this kind of decision
tree learning together with
some probabilistic i think tools
won the latest competition in 2019 and
then nobody could beat it
so just one clarification no
that won the competition since 2017
since then cvc4 has incorporated not all
of these but some of these techniques
and now cbc4 has the the
the smt search you know the the
verification tightly integrated with
this enumerative search
and that actually beats everything
so that's that's the current winner and
it's at a stage where in fact it's a
bit of a yeah it's uh it's very hard to
beat that
so that's why we are so last year we did
not have any
tools which even attempted to beat it
yeah
i see i see um but my question was i
guess about the decision tree learning
part
so what's the depth of the decision tree
considered in this process so how
how deep this decision trees can grow
and whether it would be interesting to
look at the optimal size decision trees
in terms of interpretability of course
yeah yeah now that's a great question we
haven't looked at that but in terms of
the the ones that the you know the
current tools produce
i guess it would be i
i don't know for sure but i i suspect it
would be like five or six yeah
so no not uh you know deep enough to
make the expressions complicated
but it's uh yeah it's not like super dp
also yeah i see i see okay my last
question
is about the last framework as i said
super interesting framework
um when you said that you cannot
currently handle this mixed attacks and
this was my first question that i had
but you already answered that
but did you identify why the tool fails
there
can it not differentiate between two
unknowns
or is there something that machine
learning can do in between for example
so the uh so
actually this kitsune also cannot handle
mixed attacks
there may have been more recent work
with from the machine learning community
that handles mixed attacks
now why does our tools fail you have a
good question
but i don't know the answer to that i
mean this is very recent work and
it just uh it does we know that it
doesn't work it feels
uh miserable if there is a mixed attack
here
okay very interesting i'll think about
it thank you
sanji i see that you
turn on our screen so your video
camera so do you have no
i no i didn't have a question uh just
just had a comment at the end but
thank you rajiv for a really excellent
tutorial
okay thanks
yeah are there any more questions i mean
uh i have a question
rajiv let's say we stay like two minutes
three more minutes so
did you guys also consider to use like
uh
continuous optimization tools like
nonlinear optimization tools because it
looks to me you have
a lot of discrete optimization plus plus
some theories you know associated with
them but
yeah so uh yeah so the question is the
how do you mix you know how do you so
that's actually related to can you use
say for example
neural networks okay so i could i could
map the program
the expression into some vector and then
you know try to apply some machine
learning technique and then the gradient
descender would uh
form something you know would uh
correspond to
the marketing system so there is this is
an active
area so i guess one work where which is
kind of closest is this
uh swara chaudhary's work where he talks
about neurosymbolic search so you have
uh
yeah he combines basically
research
[Music]
but it's definitely something to be
explored more yeah
yeah i think i just want to make the
comment uh which is
that next week we're planning to have
a follow-up session uh where we'll have
talk
have talks on algorithms for cyclist
solving so
some of the people have been very active
in the recent cyclists competitions we
plan to invite them to talk about
the underlying algorithms so i think i
hope this will be of interest to to many
of the attendees today
and also rajiv's last answer we'll also
have another session on
these machine learning inspired
approaches to synthesis
uh maybe a couple of sessions later on
so all of this is coming
yes so i think with this you know we are
looking forward to see you next week's
uh
as uh mentioned we are going to go
deeper into what was presented today and
what
ben presented so we are looking forward
to have you
rajiv thank you very much again for
doing this
and i think with this we can declare the
session for today
closed and uh looking forward to see you
again
thank you very much yeah thank you and
if you have any questions
you know feel free
thank you thank you guys thanks bye